hey guys I'm Ryan Wright analyst have
you crazy
we're gonna check out the video that I
was like hell yeah I'm checking this out
dad's react to their daughters getting
cat called
yes alright let's see some horrible
things and we tried to capture cat
calling that's where those let's go
this is where we're starting from that's
what we're Jetta this is the beginning
okay good Wow
my favorite boyfriend girl read this and
just keep on going yeah
I know just happens and you just keep on
strong
respect like how some barista oh god I
don't how often is that do you think
that that happens I mean I'm just seeing
clips of it obviously they don't say
that when you and I rock it out
rehearing at that on the way here yeah
cuz you're what do any of that
no um but yeah it's usually an everyday
thing street harassment 96 homicide
animal Sorrell
huh
that bag you know is pretty full and it
does have a clasp on it so that you know
she would lose anything if she had to
smack somebody in the head with it I'm
thinkin I don't know what you mean very
nice
you meant on the cars the passing by did
he set it to you I think he said it to
you you're very nice
there's no problem though yeah I think
you're very nice too
she is beautiful he's not lying
so yeah especially you gotta focus
there's no way in the world but your to
keep living witness to this that anybody
is that they're really and you are he's
all men have dual Oh respect a young
girl walking on the street not to come
so strong when I just got into trouble
I'm married baby what's okay welcome to
that's upset at me now the way he talked
the way he was no shame coming on like
this on the street without even knowing
the young lady
you're so sweet oh they say it's really
good
our you looked us and wife and mother
are to be treated with respect
if you were present and he was doing
this in front what would you say I think
there would be a fistfight then I think
there'll be a fistfight any you don't
[ __ ] with my daughter I I respect this
man did that guy was legit I would not
[ __ ] with that man holy crap that's the
kind of guy like what he says his word
is a law it started off with like yes
she is beautiful in
and it was like who the [ __ ] do these
men think they are he got so mad and it
was hilarious okay
he was like straight up following you
stalking her yeah beyond just cat
calling that's something totally
different
oh yeah I know that is uh that's nothing
illegal in some way has to be probably
yeah somehow somehow I don't know law
but I'd break it all the time this
happens to me all the time like
yesterday I I kid you not
yesterday I went to park my car to walk
a block to go to my house now what do
you mean by park your car as in I drove
up to the sidewalk and I parked I put it
in park and then I got out and I walked
so wasn't a sexual innuendo no I was
literally put on my car into park to
leave it there okay so continue your
story that has no sexual thing so I
walked literally was like less than a
block back to my house and there's this
really old who's like probably in his
mid 60's he's not like really old but
like mid 60s I want to say stout man he
was he was fairly large had like a biker
stache like old white hair and I was
just walking by and like a second that I
passed him it was like mmhmm yeah that's
it mmm and I'm like oh not okay I felt
violated it was like it wasn't in like a
it wasn't like a yeah baby yeah kind of
way it was like oh I don't eat you for
dinner
it's okra nasty kind of like hmm okay
that's what worked on Veronica well see
but that's you like it like when you do
something like that it's okay cuz it's
you what but not fat sure guys than me
not like oh my god what's that what's
that guy the diabetes guy he look like
him what you know you don't
diabetes guy talking about the diabetes
guy Oh
what young people is diet
here no oh my god with the faces just
like that guy why do you think all that
I wanted to bring up another point okay
they say 96% of American woman forty
years of age and under actually have
experienced sexual street harassment
yeah yeah what's funny is only a five
percent of guys do and I'm part of that
five percent
really oh yeah that's what's been done
to you like what do girls how do women
cat call you what is their preferred
method well if I'm like walking like
let's say I have a jacket or good let's
say I'm walking and I have like a jacket
on okay and like it's leather girls are
always like what's up George Lopez and
every lady wants George Lopez so when
they say I look like George Lopez
and there's it like all the subscribers
like they're always saying it look like
this wrestler named rusev okay and every
time a lady sees me with my shirt off
let's say I just happen to be having my
shirt off like I casually do usually
yeah you do yeah she's like damn you
look like rusev and then she asked for
my number
that's just assuming that everybody
knows who that is I was trying to tone
this down to see like would you believe
me at all if I took this you know I
actually had a question I yeah you even
own a water jacket uh no no but I do own
a UH Abercrombie & Fitch Janelle
Hollister I had a Hollister jacket same
thing perfect cool it move but no it's
[ __ ] up that woman have to experience
that you know like if I'm a guy and a
girl like walks by me if she was to be
like damn then I'd be like that's a
[ __ ] compliment oh sweet but then
women get it so often that it's like
it's like they're just treated as an
object at this point it's it's not even
that it's just cuz no I'm not in touch
with the female intuition here I thought
I might have had well I mean ya know you
do have a point but it's more than that
is what I'm trying okay
it's just making sure there's a point
where guys think it's okay to do that
for whatever reason and it's not even
like introducing yourself like hey I
just wanted to let you know that I think
you're really pretty I don't know if you
get that a lot but I just wanted to say
like thanks for being you it's not that
kind of thing it's like that's what you
want a guy to see you're so attractive I
want to take you home right now I would
respect somebody if they just like we're
like hey my name is this
you're just a super cool lady that's
kind of Awesome but like guys now they
just think it's okay to it's demeaning
it's extremely demeaning and it's gross
I mean do you honestly expect us to I
turn you and be like I'm gonna be like
oh yes thank you that's exactly what I
need in my life
take me home right now like it doesn't
work like that I don't understand what
goes through guys heads when they act
that way
cuz it's just not okay it's really not
like there's a certain way to do it
where it is okay but most of the time
they don't do it that way it's just it's
taken totally out of control it's gross
okay it's demeaning and grow okay okay
whatever no no no respect woman you're
all out of it anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Alyssa be
crazies channel where there's fun [ __ ]
of her all over the place on that
channel and you could follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope you have a periscope yet I
don't you [ __ ] I know I know I'm
so sorry I failed you I'm gonna go now
baby Papa Papa I'm sorry that's my new
way of saying goodbye to people
baby bad bad bad bad bad even if I'm in
a really bad fight with Veronica I'm
like [ __ ] you I'm out of here
baby papa
and it always breaks the mood then we
totally make up because N Sync gets you
in sync with love this video is brought
to you by NSYNC no you dumbass a [ __ ]
[ __ ] could you [ __ ] beat
Veronica's shut up with the [ __ ] ELISA